[Music]
Ryan Reynolds recently spoke about the
third Deadpool part and to the delight
of many fans its future release after a
long period of retie since about that
pool three Reynolds now grab the bomb at
a press conference in China he will
definitely come back as Deadpool that
wasn't always certain despite the
outstanding first two box office results
Reynolds himself had doubts after all
furthermore Reynolds revealed that that
full three would take a completely
different approach since according to
him characters and film sequels are
changed too late or not at all which is
why the team were probably apt for the
radical path of reinvention it's also
likely that that pool team will have
least go for the tried and tested behind
the camera as director david leitch has
already expressed his interest and even
though screenwriters will probably not
be replaced due to risk minimization
more details haven't come to light yet
and it will certainly take quite some
time until Deadpool 3 is finally
produced although the production start
of fantastic piece 3 should already have
started partially Warner Brothers will
probably have to postpone production
until the end of this year despite the
divided opinions about the second part
the box office results were quite
successful the postponement of the
production also fits Warner's new
approach since in the path they wanted
to release big productions quickly
however now the focus is more on meeting
the audience needs and not pushing a
release too fast in terms of content we
can count again on Eddie Redmayne as
Newt Scamander
and the relationship between Dumbledore
and Grindelwald will probably also play
a role after the exciting end of the
second part the cinema lounge is
currently still planned for 2020 yet due
to the current delay it's not sure when
we could finally see fantastic beast 3
in movie theaters according to reliable
sources from this week's deadline
magazine it was confirmed that there
will be most certainly a second part of
bumblebee and this despite the fact that
the 2018 transformers spin-off generated
rather modest revenues in the u.s.
especially compared to past
warmest films in the rest of the world
however the story about the yellow
beetle and its youthful own who found
many new fans which is why the producers
decided to create a second part of the
movie which in contrast to its Big
Brother transformers is cheap to produce
surprisingly the ratings of the first
part was so high that bumblebee didn't
even have to hide behind those
simultaneously released movies Mary
Poppins returned and Aquaman of course
nothing is known about the plot yet but
there are already speculations according
to the Deadland magazine namely that
Bumblebee and Optimus Prime could appear
side by side in the sequel many fans
wish for an absence prime solo movie
anyway which is why this wouldn't be an
unlikely scenario at all we are curious
when we will see bumblebee and Charlie
Watson in front of the camera because so
far we don't know any details about the
start of the production or of a planned
release after the Star Wars Celebration
had to be cancelled in 2018 they will
give it a new this year from April 11th
to 15th an important save the day not
only for die-hard Star Wars fans but
also for film fans in general since
there is a high chance that you can
expect trailers for Star Wars Episode
nine and two series the Mandalorian in
addition a brand new poster was released
and the names of the stars including
Chewbacca actor Jonah Stuart amo
we're announced which will answer some
critical questions for the fans the post
is reminiscent of a mix of the nostalgia
of the old films and the modernity of
the newer parts as well as a cut through
the dark and brad side of power the
final actors who will appear at the
celebration aren't fully known yet which
probably has to do with the fact that
there are some much bigger names in
stock we don't know yet who will join
their acting colleagues so we were all
the more eagerly waiting for further
announcements for the Star Wars
Celebration in April of 2019
streaming giant Netflix could become
significantly more expensive in the
future according to its own statement
Netflix is currently still in a test
phase with the aim to find out how
existing and new customers react to a
higher price
depending on the subscription this can
add up up to four heroes a month
Netflix gives the all-clear signal that
they just want to test the reaction of
customers anyways in the past such test
phases were followed by price increases
few months later as we last saw in
summer 2017 so it remains exciting
whether we will actually have to pay
more for the streaming service in the
future or rather the test phase is
really just a test phase
[Music]